five years ago I got called the
emergency room to see a patient who had
blockage of all major arteries of the
heart not an unusual event unfortunately
this country we do a couple hundred
thousand of these coronary artery bypass
grafting operations a year but wonder
when I went down to the room I opened
the curtain and I was looking at a 25
year old Latino woman and I was shocked
and I realized that this whole time that
I thought we were improving health care
in America by figuring out better ways
doing bypass surgery on people we were
missing the boat because if a 25 year
old is having the disease of a 60 year
old we are advocating our responsibility
to make a difference in the health of
the youth of America and so I created
health Corps which is an organization
just like the Peace Corps fact thanks to
the Peace Corps we follow many of the
same tricks they use to just for success
for example we take young college
graduates we've got all that vital
energy and enthusiasm and we put them
instead of sub-saharan Africa and build
aims we put them in high schools around
the country to teach kids only a few
years under than them about their bodies
they make it edgy and they make it hip
and it's cool to learn about your body
from some of only a couple years older
than you am i creating these kinds of
mentorship programs we can take
volunteers put them in schools and train
a lot of kids and we make them into
activists because at the end of the day
it's not just about what you eat and how
your exercise is about mental resilience
i did get tough enough to deal with the
modern world and health course seeks to
get these kids tough enough to go out
and change the food that are available
in their environments they they get them
to go home and audit their refrigerator
they get them to make a difference and
that's I hope my legacy that we trained
a generation of folks who will not
appreciate it how special the most
valuable thing they wear be given their
bodies really are